death grip yeah those guys which brings
us to the last fight man yeah death grip
yeah that Ben Askren fight dude I've
watched that fight I've watched that
finish like 10 times trying to figure
out what happened or whether it was out
or whether it wasn't out I was pretty
convinced that at one point time he went
out and then tomorrow
Uman changed my mind tomorrow iseman
showed that we watched the videotape
together he's like no no he's given a
thumbs up in like shit yeah okay so I'm
still kids because the angles I've seen
haven't been the best I'm trying to see
this thumbs up what's the thumb going up
or was the thumb in a thumbs up position
going this way right like as the arm
drops was the okay so when I give
somebody a thumbs up like let's say
somebody want a job you want this job do
you know I mean I don't know like I mean
I saw one of them's nobody's gonna know
whether he was conscious or unconscious
what I saw I saw everything that would
indicate I'm seeing an unconscious
fighter I see an arm go limp for no
reason whatsoever and so that's what I'm
that's what I have to work with because
that's what you know we don't know what
someone's feeling whatever we just see
if they're doing something that doesn't
make sense and you see an arm go limp at
that time you're gonna assume that the
person is unconscious we assumed it yeah
as the broadcast team yeah thank you
guys and and and that I'm supposed to do
certain things and like so here's the
thing with that joke when I'm referring
fights you know there's some times where
you know some positions are anxiety like
you know you see two guys going up two
leg locks you see a noodle mess of legs
and you know you got a you're gonna have
to help one guy out and we figure out
who's tapping and make sure you're on
the right arm when I see some choke so
rear naked choke specially got on the
back face up I took a sigh of relief my
job just got so much easier this guy you
know it's not like he's gonna go out and
then a second take some extreme amount
of damage he may go out I'll have a
second to make sure it's not even a
second a half a breath to make sure he's
okay and then let it go out and he's not
going to take any other damage a bulldog
choke we have anytime you have a choke
where somebody's where where there's
pressure on
the neck and there's bending bending the
c-spine backwards like that that's a
that's a rough situation for me so I see
someone go limp and I know that on top
of it they're no longer putting tension
on their neck and their neck is just
being bent I can't
I you know I can't see that I should do
something different than that because
that's the arm I like to talk to people
about this I'd like to talk to people
have opinions about fights especially
people who are interested in who they
know what they're talking about
because if I always have a situation if
I was having mindset that I'm always
doing the right thing I can't get better
so I'm gonna have to look at something
and say is there you know a teachable
moment there is there a way I can learn
from this and is there a way I could do
something different and no I don't I
think with that same situation with an
arm going limp with that type of a choke
on someone I don't know of a defense
that requires the arm you know I mean I
would think the arm should be doing
something else I at this time I don't
know I don't see that I should do
something different you know I'm always
interested in always looking and always
I love these type of conversations but
right now I can't think of you know you
know they sell you something it was an
amazing fight it was yeah it was I mean
first of all was the first time I seen I
refereed Ben Askren I didn't think I'd
refereed him before and you know when
you're at his prayer his pressure or
something special it's not the normal
and the way Robby dealt with it and
Robby had him and he had him in trouble
you know it's so close to stopping that
fight when they're on the ground yes so
many times yeah yeah it's a bomb yeah
the the the amount of respect I have for
those two athletes man it's like so
that's so that's the thing is you know
we never want to see anything that could
make you that have a feeling that it's
inconclusive but I can't think of what
else I should have done but you know I
mean especially for that that fight for
those two guys you know yeah you always
want it yeah the people would have a
feeling of conclusion there well when we
talked about on the phone when you
brought up the damage the possible
damage to that neck with the Bulldog
choke you might be cutting off nerves
and you might be bending the spine and
in a kind of a fucked-up way yeah I
really hadn't considered that well not
what I was thinking of the choke when he
grabbed hold them I was just thinking it
was a blood choke but you're right like
the way you
in on walldog choke you lean back yeah
that's a lot of pressure on the neck
I've had some chokes where there
I've refereed a fight where a guy did
one of these moves that you had to move
for it a technique where he's been in
the spine back Wooster I wasn't a
twister I think guys have a name for you
do you know what the executioner is so
that's what it was that's what it is
that explains people to what that is is
like if a guy is okay not to cut you off
okay so for so long I've never really
want to talk about it because people
weren't doing it this was years ago I
saw it but not there's a name for it I
guess it's okay but you hadn't seen a
lot of people doing it before right well
we we started doing it in tenth planet a
few years back it's I think people have
done it what it is basically folks it's
like our guillotine from the back it's
like taking a rear naked choke hooks but
instead of choking guys this way which
is how you would do it which is wrap
your forum underneath his neck and wrap
the other arm behind his head instead of
doing that you wrap your arm all the way
around the front like a guillotine hold
but from the back and you have ungodly
leverage right it's ungodly how much
pressure you could put on someone's neck
and our friend Scott Epstein he he used
it quite a few times so we called it the
AB Secutor is that it there om trying to
find a picture of while this arm no this
is this is the executioner choke this is
a different choke he calls it the AB
secure I look that up and nothing came
up okay I think I might have a have a
have it here for you the something like
this this is a little different this guy
had arms in this is different but it's
similar
yeah it's similar though that's similar
yeah you can have arms in yeah that's
the same thing yeah this is it that's a
100% it so um I don't know we're gonna
show people that either way it's a real
bad place to be in okay I got it yeah
that's okay that's bad Epstein that's
the north/south choke but what he would
do if he wanted to do an AB Secutor is
he would get his hips underneath the
and get back position this is just a
really good north-south show so yes so
what I saw was the guy who went north
south and he this was years ago at a
king of the cage and way out in
Wisconsin and he had wow this is a long
long time ago he had north/south and he
sat up once he had the guy he sat up and
pulled the guy's body up onto him and
almost a sitting position and then put
hooks right and then I've done it before
where you all roll the guy to the side
just to walk it through and figure out
how it worked
he put hooks and I was sitting I was
like okay this isn't illegal if I stop
this fight it's not you know this is not
an illegal move but I don't want to see
how this plays out and the guy got one
hook in and almost the second hook was
about to go in a guy tapped and when I
pulled him off the guy couldn't move his
neck was fucked up yeah he couldn't move
you know he had some sort of stinger I
don't know what's gone he well he was he
couldn't move he was terrified I was
terrified okay and then it kind of you
know came back came back Jesus yeah I
know of several guys that have gone
paralyzed because of Defense from
guillotine or trying to take a guy down
right yeah you know when someone gets in
a guillotine yeah I've heard of that
yeah so so that's why with some
submissions you know especially some of
the chokes it's like okay things are
slowing down and okay things are getting
a little bit easier for me with that one
things are not easy at all that's not
something that I want to I want to play
what I think if you know I'm kind of
disappointed with some some people have
a platform I don't want to mention any
names but some people have a platform of
kind of tossed it out it was something
sensational and say oh look at this is
it wrong or right I think that's a
little bit responsible when it's some
dangerous techniques like that well I
think you really pointed that out about
the neck and a very important way and I
think that's something that people
should really take into consideration
when you see someone you've seen people
if you ever afraid someone who got
caught in a twister yeah mm-hmm it's a
horrible place to be yeah yeah it's a
horrible place to be it's so your
so fucked up and there's so much
pressure and the fact that your that
your left legs isolating your heads
getting pulled it feels like it's gonna
break it's a fucked up place to be even
for the fact of the way it's set up
because it's not like it it's not like a
fast thing that catches you off-guard
it's a long road to it yeah so you know
it's coming and you're like I'm doing
this but I know how this is gonna
probably end and you're doing some
little bit yeah yeah there's a chance
Hong Kong Korean Zombie yeah I think he
got the first ever one on Leonard Garcia
I think yeah first look at that and then
I see no horrible dude that is so that
is so bad that feels so terrible yeah
and that that's a he then there's DEFCON
4 we need to take a rear naked choke
grip from the twisted position oh yeah
okay that's just you just ripping dudes
heads clean off it's horrible
you know those all those crazy like
catch wrestling neck manipulation those
things make my neck hurt just looking at
them yeah yeah yeah yeah so anyway yeah
that's that's why I think you know you
can't always say look at things as good
or bad but you know some situations I've
seen referees and and that one I think
is a difficult situation not so I've
seen other harder situations but you
know I mean like yeah it's an unusual
one yeah I mean we've seen quite a few
bulldog chokes that put someone
unconscious most recently Raquel
Pennington against Ashlee evans-smith
amazing fight crazy fight for Cowpens is
so fucking tough I mean that was just
that was a crazy fight man it was just
war and chaos and then with like one
second to go she chokes her out and then
lets her go and she's she's asleep from
the Bulldog choke and Ashlee evans-smith
steps up covered in blood and he was
fuckin crazy
that was crazy but there's that one
didn't Chris lights out Lydell catch
Tiki in a bulldog choke I think he did
we're gonna garlic that's the side yeah
that's the though yeah that looked
really tight yeah go to forget that go
to yeah that's the world a Carlos Newton
chokes out Pat Miletich because this was
for the title and he caught him in a
bulldog choke and it
like that was that was I think we had a
name for I think we used to call it a
schoolyard headlock but yeah then
somebody called it a bulldog choke at
that time I remember people are calling
it Bulldog Joe how like they are it
already had that I don't know if it had
there maybe they gave it to but yeah
it's a legit move mm-hmm I get so legit
move I'll give you specially if you're a
badass current type dude with that kind
of grip right alright if someone's neck
in that position yeah yes horrible yeah
that was um that's why I say that
referees have the hardest job because
you're you're in that situation you do
have to take those things into
consideration what kind of damages is
doing this guy's neck is he out is his
arm went limp okay when do I still I
gotta get I gotta save him like ya know
that that is the tough part about it you
know you were evaluating a situation as
always there's different that you know
and you're evaluating the threat to the
person you're evaluating if there's a
threat coming you how much how well can
they deal with it yeah there's a lot of
stuff going on there and you know we
take it really serious I take it really
serious it's to me it's um it's uh I
feel that I have a secret trust I feel
that it's one of these positions that
like our athletes are not stupid people
a lot of them could be doing a lot of
things with their life and they've
chosen this path too and they take time
from their family they take time away
from other careers where they could be
progressing and all to meet their dreams
and hopes and I need to balance that
with their safety so it's something I
think about a lot
you know the main arm I'm even in the
way uh I talked to my friends you know I
mean to always you know I I'm always on
I'm always working as a referee anytime
I'm out in the streets or with friends
people gonna ask me and what do I think
about this fight or who do I think can
be better and I because of this job
you're doing you don't longer have the
the luxury of having you know of talking
about mixed martial arts in the fun way
about who's gonna win and how's this
gonna happen because who knows I might
referee the fight right and everyone's
gonna be on the internet like hers
refereeing the fight and we're having
beers yesterday and guess what he told
me right right yes just you know so yeah
I take it serious no you do it I'm glad
you have that attitude what is this one
right here oh yeah this is chrome this
is Carl's right here yeah yeah in the
transition he grabs the neck and it's a
crazy visual too because the photograph
the fru-u-- see the muscle right there
right there
I'm daddy's crazy muscles and Carlos's
arm and shoulder and neck look at that
Carlos Newton champion of the world
right there that moment in that crazy
Carlos had some spectacular grappling
Rome early on man
wild transition he was amazed it sue his
uh his his explosiveness his agility and
he was just he was so athletic he was
doing stuff that no one else yeah he
also had a really high level submission
game early on yeah we looked in 96 97 a
lot of people didn't have that kind of a
game and his submission game was tight
the the Matt Hughes one was crazy
remember that yeah yeah that was crazy
that uh go choke where he had him up and
yeah he's yeah that was he puts him to
sleep on as they get up Matt Hughes like
here's coroner saying like stand up you
won you want he's like what happened
yeah yeah yeah yeah double knockout yeah
yeah I have that one I have one the king
of the cage a double knockout is right
here yeah this is look how guy takes him
strong yeah he used was he was so
fucking strong that holds him up there
and Carlos is trying to so he's easy
squeazy he's squeezing so Matt goes
unconscious he's out cold
he doesn't know what's going on no one
knows what's going on and they get they
they so Carlos his head hit the ground
when he went down like that and then
knocked him out right right right and
then Matt woke up from the choke and
then like you won yeah what it's great
that was a crazy scene that that scene
was a tough one that was like what do
you do there yeah well that was like the
thing about this robbie lawler penetrant
fight like Guzman was saying they gotta
run it back and I was like it wouldn't
be a bad thing to run it back
I mean well at the same time you know we
got to be honest here like as far as
running it back how many of the fights
is that happened in the UFC are there
because it's exciting what people want
to see Joe most right so Brock Lesnar DC
is a perfect example right so that's
exciting is people want to see it and
and some of the citement has been
generated by throwing me under the bus
but cool
give the people another time I'll take
it I got but ya know so yeah I think you
know anytime that you know the athletes
get to do what they do and people are
gonna watch it again and people are
gonna be excited about it you know I
don't know